l a tutti ragazzi è proprio questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo 5
è inseribile devo conoscere tutti fieri
che ho fatto nanni secoli fa aveva avuto
un successo che mango gesù in realtà
l'anno aggiornato e hanno messo questa
cosa che adesso sembra un demonio e non
so perché hanno messo questa cosa però è
raccapricciante per questo videogame è
praticamente riesce a riconoscerti la
faccia e a imitare coi personaggi quello
che fai tipo oddio oddio cosa cazzo
cliccato fermi no no hanno dio ti
sembrate realizzare manova perché
grafico bevuto un po di red bull che mi
ha messo le ali
beh direi che può passare questa cosa
molto brutta ora che ha comunque ho
deciso di fare feist ring perché hanno
aggiunto un sacco di personaggi tipo è
già ma perché c'è un bambino dentro la
mia bocca po la mia preferiti o quello
della birra cazzolato 6 senza ma ciao
tesoro per te che non ci vediamo hanno
aggiunto gli animi sono natsuko nat su
coach ascolta su chi è
e serio sono una tipa e ciò è vero c'è
perché è un velociraptor dovrebbe
parlare che restava che gli occhi ei bel
maschione nono velociraptor sì ma non ha
letto di un grafico comunque volevo che
cos'è sta roba ma che cupido è un qubit
ubriachi stimolante sverso gente vice è
una birra ha aggiunto dall'ultima volta
che conta un pupazzo anno questo piacerà
pesano snowman quanto è triste triste
ragazzi perché c'ha le sopracciglia nel
naso
cosa che non ho capito perché è però la
veda in avevo questa la mangia vista
[Musica]
e sì salve vorrei ordinare una pizza
prosciutto e patatine la bassa prendere
e tra poco allora e loro non sapranno
mai che è stato frankenstein ordinare
questa pizza sono un clown horror
ciò vuol dire che faccio battute
dell'orrore vuoi sentire una barzelletta
dell'orrore è uno scherzo dice all'altro
inserito parlaste non facevi girerà
oppure il colmo piero due scheletri
essere amici per la pelle non facevano
cambiamo avatar ragazzi mettiamo questa
qui a jane da jane perché c'è la bocca
dentro la bocca jane l'aver cos'era
questa roba dio mio james ma mai visto
un film romantico addio mio la mostra
brasile almeno dallo strano lecce molto
realistiche talk ma che cazzo dici
aspetta non è una reggia data la fragola
questo che ciò sul naso anche il
tacchino per rimorchiare come
sopracciglia ormai in molti hanno tutti
con le sopracciglia regala una cosa
fissa di più di me veramente c'è più di
pane ma come per quale cazzo di motivo
hanno messo più di pine fei street bar
ei pub j alza il browser non ce l'hanno
l'alzava beh dai arriveremo in futuro
fammi cercare altre cose no più di cerco
io states è fermato o 10 dren out cioè
tipo i tre doubt questa era una gran
gnocca ai tempi dio mio ma la gara che
si guarda che ti colpisce
anima comunque hanno messo anche il
fantasma di del round ma com'è possibile
guarda al cefa vj suoi ragazzi sono più
raccapricciante io che ciò gli occhi
rossi e rispettate si prova prima la
bocca ogni tanto è questa e la cosa piu
nuova che hanno aggiunto secondo me che
sono le cose in 2d
quante fine ho sempre voluto essere un
[ __ ] personaggio di unanime e poi mi
si sta chiedendo lacchio sempre così ma
avete visto niente voi non avete visto
niente liga e toto dai ma che sa se sia
stato sta a tenere la mano sul culo
perché sa di essere gnocca che cazz jazz
di bella lei bella lei che sa di essersi
gas che dicono di solito le tipe negli
anime che sono in questa posizione dove
si che possa essere interessata a te che
non so perché di cosa queste cagate tipo
free enzo o di consumi che sembra l di
della stoffa segue state banca linguaggi
e fai la dubstep con gli occhi pure e
come ultimo ragazzi un bar
juan è la madonna buon corro mocchi
[Musica]
io non so dove viva questo cane di chi
sia ma lo voglio
ok ma dopo cvc bellissimo ragazzo la
madonna quando mi sveglio la mattina a
te lo giuro zia siamo uguali non c'è
problema per la pietrificazione tanto
shortcut le marmotta giorno ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio è stato
veramente figlio però devo andare a
prendere la pizza e niente ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto e spero che
abbiate tutti imparato che c'è una volta
è dentro ognuno di noi
pronta a ordinare la pizza
quindi ragazzi niente è servito vi è
piaciuto ma senza al centro commento è
un mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
con ivy notate nella descrizione stasera
city sia i medici mediano prossimo vita
della ragazza